hey guys i'm ryan right hi there I'm
Veronica Veronica did a cover of a song
called bad blood by Taylor Swift there's
a video out called bat blood a Batman V
Superman and bad blood parody aa
featuring Batman
this is from how it should have ended
one of the greatest YouTube channels
ever
maybe now we've just there you know we
used to be best buds so take a look what
you've become
cuz baby now we've got bad blood hey you
can't make the bed look where we are
you used to be the GGC this bhe is why
tobe Nolan my back now you and me are
it's about to share no I hate to break
it to you snoo you is to love a sequel
it's don't know feature or release you
pajamaed opinion you can't prepare no
more that's when my pelvis bone snaps
neck you lost respect no it's warm
oh it's so sad to think of all the
coffee you and I just baby now we've got
bad blood you know we used to loggers Oh
so take a look what you've become baby
now we've got bad blood right and the
router making video
chillin in the sweet baby now we've got
bad blood hey you tried Lois and Clark
remember when you thought returns boss
man still completely gay fathers and
Jesus you don't know how to lead us it
was my season for Russell pools
superstars back fruit bruised stabbed in
Masada Tory's got dumped over from all
that time I was money and power you
gotta live with the bad blood now oh
this is not the sequel this is not the
reboot this is just the door cuz maybe
now we got bad blood you know we used to
be best buds so take a look what you
pick up your we got bad blood hey we got
thing you're not just here just you and
and baby now we've got bad blood right
band-aids don't fix melting holes that
someone's gotta pay for those do you
have the cash
oh no you're broke but I'll never let it
go and it's your fix me things expired
say you're sorry whoops - slightly keep
this up we'll all be killed
so let's go you did you leave like that
we used to beat this pretty awesome
actually would you Robin Mason they got
a suicide baby now we got bad blood
maybe no he got bad blood you know it
used to be bad blood you take a look
what you've become
- baby now we've got bad blood hey now
we drop it and they're out making me
they got a really sweet baby now we got
bad blood that was pretty cool man that
was really cool I love how they took all
these pop-culture all these iconic movie
characters and just threw them all and
this like for me as a guy who is so into
movies that was a million times more
rewarding than actually watching the
actual music video which I like but I
just I'd rather watch this and the rap
was cool the parody was funny
yeah even till they put like actual time
and energy into creating a track with it
yeah
but the lyrics and the singing and
having to do that boys Batman voice I
like the Batman voice oh wow I never
knew you were such a Taylor Swift fan
well we do have a history you do not so
you think she's singing about her last
up no way not in your wildest dreams
well don't you sound jelly shake it off
oh I tell you one thing about tannaz
with you back what's that we never go
out of style cute yeah I love the how it
should have ended she's never seen how
it should have ended in him like that
they bring that's like the Batman
Superman personality they have on there
it's inspiring to see channels that do
so much work like that I mean they have
millions of followers and it makes sense
why when you see like just the level of
commitment that they put on something on
the internet that's a genuinely
entertaining show like it's something
that maybe television wouldn't have
given a chance but you see that millions
of people like it and it's just online
and they consistently watch it and it's
like that's something where I can see it
being like on Comedy Central or
something yeah you know no there's like
no boundaries on this plot
could do whatever you want yeah for porn
sure your tit oh yeah you can show your
tits
you can't I've seen videos on YouTube
with tits like movie footage or like
yeah actual people showing their tits
movie footage um science tutorials oh
well yeah you tell me about that you
told everybody about it yeah you should
show your kids this science is like an
anatomy channel actually share kids you
want me to share my tits with why you
haven't shown me your tits until never -
who - me it's baby now we've got bad - I
did bad blood genius that means the time
of the month anyway guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out
Veronica's channel acoustic covers vlogs
and originals - check it out and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine periscope e
Christian Hernandez hey Ryan and the
real rejects hi it'd be fantastic if I
got a shout-out
I drew this of you and Veronica and call
it unreeled love two E's no a thanks for
making me laugh every day since your
reaction to the first announcement
trailer of Mortal Kombat X I just
graduated high school meaning you can go
to strip clubs and I'm on my way to join
the air force
go to the strip club before you go to
the air force or I'll still have sex
with a lot of men in the Air Force
that's your thing then totally okay when
I finish I'd like to become a great
artist where I can perfect my work and
be well-known yes yes I believe you
sincerely Christian here's us baby
that's my right cheek all the way that
looks like I'm slab a swollen right
cheek
oh they look so much happier than we
actually on the [ __ ] power I just say
that I mean look how like extremely
thrilled they look this was from the
photo we first took years ago that like
when we were just friends and I lived at
the other oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's like me when I was like 19 that's
when we were just friends times were
much easier than